bonjour et bienvenue dans ce dernier
numéro de l'année dans vie de lecture
autour de moi aujourd'hui deux invités
pauline amiez bonjour je vous êtes la
directrice de librairie le pavé du canal
et armelle rigaud bonjour vous êtes la
responsable des manifestations
culturelles et scientifiques de la
bibliothèque universitaire de saint
quentin en yvelines et vous êtes venu
nous parler aujourd'hui d'un livre d'un
coup de coeur d'un livre chargée
d'émotion c'est qui le livre de l'année
pour vous oui le lambeau voilà le
lambeau de philippe lançon donc on voit
l'image
donc pour moi c'est le livre de la nuit
c'est un coup de coeur
parce qu'on est impressionnés par par ce
livre par son contenu et surtout ses
émotions et on reste avec lui il vous
accompagne pendant de nombreux mois
après sa lecture
donc je restitue philippe lançon c'est
un journaliste à libération à charlie
hebdo est aussi écrivain et qui fait
partie des rares survivants de la tacc
de charlie hebdo qui est qui va décrire
par le menu
l'attentât est ensuite la reconstruction
les l'émoi d'hôpitaux voilà cinq ans
d'aller 500 fait c'est sa traversée
puisque il est journaliste il hésite ce
jour là en janvier de l'église à nos
coeurs voilà il hésite entre aller à
libé ou plutôt charlie hebdo c'est la
première conférence
malheureusement il gare son vélo il va
cette conférence et sa vie bascule dans
l'horreur et ce livre retrace en fait
c'est un récit un témoignage
cette traversée ces traversées et aussi
également c'est un livre chargé d'espoir
parce que malgré ses trois premiers mois
parce qu'il va subir quand même dit
cette opération il est conduit à l'api
trice à la pitié salpêtrière dans le
service de stomatologie chirurgie
maxillo-faciale et là en fait
il va subir 17 opérations et se livre ce
qui est intéressant
bon je suis pas la seule puisque il a
été vendu à plus de 160 mille
exemplaires et l'a reçu deux prix
littéraires dont le prix spécial du jury
renaudot
c'est que c'est une horde de l'union et
le prix femina c'est une ode également à
toutes les personnes qui ont participé à
cette guérison notamment à tout le
personnel hospitalier
donc la construction de son livre je
trouve un ressemble à une pièce de
théâtre puisque c'est un ballet
incessant de personnages qui pour pau
qui il a compté et qui lui ont permis de
retrouver la force pour combattre alors
le dit un tract écrit un tract de
construction littéraire qui s'accomplit
parralèlement à la reconstruction
chirurgicale
on parle de on parle d'un blessé de
guerre le pompier qui le qui le sort du
bâtiment des locaux de charlie hebdo
parle de blessures de guerre c'est le
terme qui va revenir vraiment oui il
devient gueules cassées puisqu'il ya une
balle qui lui détruit toute la partie
intérieure la mâchoire un don qui les
conduit vraiment en urgence il ne peut
pas manger il ne peut pas parler il vit
soudain dans les premiers temps il là il
est meurtri dans sa chair mais également
dans son âme 1 il a plus envie de vannes
de vivre et ni de se battre et grâce à
sa chloé comme il dit cette chirurgienne
qui va participer à cette reconstruction
parce que le lambeau c'est un terme
médical en fait c'est une grève du
péroné qui va nous permettre refaire une
mâchoire refaire une mâchoire raven pour
on découvre en fait l'organisation de
ces services qui nous rend donc il ya
des on pense à bille le brancardier on
pince sakineh corinne qui a subi la même
chose que lui d'une certaine façon ce
qu'elle a été défigurée on pense
également j'aime beaucoup la façon dont
ils la surnomment la marquise des langes
qui va lui
cette infirmière chevronnés qu'ils
eurent fait sans pansement au quotidien
et puis bien entendu cette chirurgienne
qui est exceptionnel et qui reste dans
ses fonctions primaires c'est-à-dire
pour elle elle explique très fortement
la chirurgie c'est de redonner une
fonction à cette mâchoire et ensuite
l'esthétique passera après et puis bien
entendu ce qui est fait aussi la force
de cette de cet ouvrage c'est la
relation très forte qu'il a avec son
entourage
avec ses amis mais également il est
sauvé d'une certaine façon ils
s'enveloppe de beauté et d'art alors il
a plusieurs passions la littérature un
parce qu'ils accompagnent ces trois
auteurs un tome assmann marcel proust
avec une recherche du temps perdu et
puis quatre cas mais également la
musique avec jean sébastien bach avec le
également le jazz qui qu'il aime
beaucoup et le il continue ses
chroniques pour charlie hebdo c'est
quelqu'un qui on voit bien c'est un
journaliste érudit et qui a besoin de se
nourrir de culture pour pouvoir
retrouver l envie de vivre puisque sa
convalescence va être à l'hôpital
militaire des invalides
alors là c'est intéressant également
parce qu'on découvre l'histoire de ceux
de ce monument on oublie bien que c'est
des victimes de guerre est là également
il brosse toute une kyrielle de
personnages forts en émotion toujours
puisque sa touche de très près la vie
sans que le livre ne soit ni un essai
sur les tables hôpital ni un passage
très drôle d'ailleurs où il doit
protéger ses blessures et l'utilisent à
sac poubelle à l'hôpital pour se
protéger je crois que c'est sa compagne
qui t'a méricaine qui lui dit mais
qu'est ce que tu vas qu'elle est
vraiment l'état de l'hôpital de la 16e
puis sont allés monde pour utiliser à ce
point des sacs poubelle dans un hôpital
pour eux il n'est pas d'un côté j'ai de
l'eau les blessures lorsque il est pas
dans cette béatitude où tout le monde il
est beau tout le monde il est gentil pas
du tout et il montre aussi c'est son
métier de journaliste 1 et 2 de
critiques qui lui permet d'avoir assez
de recul
il dénonce aussi un les moyens les peu
de moyens qu'on donne à l'hôpital et
pourtant cette relation très forte un et
c'est ça qui est beau dans le livre
c'est cette relation fusionnelle entre
les soignants et les soigner et toute
l'empathie et le dévouement du personnel
médical et qui travaillent dans des
conditions parfois même très difficile
non c'est un livre que j'encourage les
personnes qui tournent autour et qui ont
peur de s'embarquer dans cette aventure
c'est un livre aussi qui vous laisse
plein de plein d'énergie plein de force
et plein d'espoir parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui aujourd'hui il va mieux
oublie t on
paulette vous l'avez vous l'avez lu
c'est tout à fait et contrairement aux
autres livres des survivants de la tacc
de charlie comme celui de luz ou de
catherine meurisse
c'est un livre beaucoup plus lumineux en
fait ça avec les gens peuvent avoir un
petit peu peur de se dire bon bah c'est
un témoignage aussi 500 pages de voilà
de ce 60 pages sur l'attentât voilà
c'est c'est violent évidemment mais sur
le tracé du terroriste enfin c'est pas
son sujet c'est pas maintenant et je
pense qu'en fait il veut pas leur prêter
leur pas tant d'importance quoi ya pas
de haine
non non non mais ni chez lui ni chez
maurice derrière mais ils ont mis plus
de temps à s'en remettre
visiblement parce qu'il y avait moins ce
côté médical qui à mon avis un rythme
qui fait qu on arrive à passer palier
par palier jusqu'à une reconstruction
totale
c'est un très bon niveau et qu'il qu'il
faut qu'il faut lire je pense que c'est
important de
voilà deux de tes de lire ce témoignage
en tout cas sur sur ce qu'est donc
l'attentât évidemment mais sur ce que ça
implique en terme de reconstruction et
que on peut quand même garder espoir et
un peu foi en l'humanité
ce qui n'est pas toujours évidente ici
armelle elle pauline vous êtes venus
nous prêter représenter un livre une
tout autre
tout à fait mais presque philippe lançon
il sera un jour il dans cette édition de
la destination des enfants
voilà donc c'est un livre documentaire
on pourrait le qualifier comme ça donc
ça s'appelle d'histoire pour garçons qui
veulent changer le monde
c'est un livre à destination des gares
sont également des petites filles
c'est une galerie de portraits
d'hommes et d'enfants qui ont changé le
monde donc à chaque fois la présentation
est similaire
une pages d'illustrations et un portrait
assez court d'hommes qui à leur échelle
alors s'il peut trouver
barack obama on trouve lionel messi et
on trouve également des inconnus des
groupes d'enfants qui à leur échelle ont
sauvé le monde alors soit sauvé le monde
dans leur ville sauver le monde dans le
statut des homosexuels par exemple pour
harvey milk voilà son combat pour la
reconnaissance est très belle et très
pédagogique c'est très pédagogique c'est
la destination d'un public de 8 9 ans
8-9 ans est très accessible voilà c'est
vraiment très court c'est un roman c'est
aussi on n'est pas dans des jeux sur
pure fait voilà c'est à permet enfin moi
ce qui m'a plu en tout cas dans ce livre
c'est de montrer aux petits garçons que
le but d'un petit garçon s'est pas
forcément d'être fort des protecteurs
d'être toujours de bien présenter de ne
jamais montrer ses émotions c'est plutôt
un livre qui montre qu'il faut être
solidaire qu'il faut être à l'écouté des
autres qu'il faut oser aussi parfois
s'affirmer prendre des risques il ya des
sportifs et notamment
un jeune surfeur qui lors d'une sortie
en mer est attaqué par un requin qui
perd une jambe alors évidemment on peut
s'attendre à ce qu'il abandonne
maintenant au contraire ya remonte sur
une planche et il se fait défenseur de
la cause des requins voilà il va aucune
haine contre cet animal parce que le
groupe appelle très bon match at 13 août
à elle très coloré cd illustration assez
moderne voilà et ça balaye voilà une
part d'auto fut suspect arrive à barack
obama donc c'est il a dit dans cette
collection
alors il existe dans la même collection
deux autres ouvrages qui sont parus
l'année dernière et l'année précédente
qui s'appelle l'histoire du soir pour
fille rebelle dont mme allard et
mazarine jour chez mazarine et c1
pendant voilà pour protéger leur santé
les garçons peuvent dire les voilà et
des films viraux les femmes et je trouve
que c'est un bel ouvrage porteurs de
plein de belles valeurs qu'on peut
trouver à la librairie tout à faire
notre à la mairie incite les histoires
du soir profite qu il coûte 19,90
parfait très bien très bel ouvrage et
j'en profite aussi pour vous présenter
deux ouvrages destination des enfants
qui ont été illustrés par une artiste
que j'aime beaucoup qui s'appelle
coralie bickford sens que vous allez
apercevoir à l'écran c'est une
illustratrice qu'il fallait beaucoup sur
le motif elle qui travaille pour
l'édition aux pingouins pinguins ar en
anglais elle travaille beaucoup sur le
motif la répétition ces deux livres très
graphique et elle a les éditions penguin
lui aurait proposé de décrire elle même
deux ouvrages donc elle a écrit deux
ouvrages à destination des enfants donc
le renard et l'étoile et en deuxième qui
vient de sortir qui est le vert et
l'oiseau donc on retrouve dans ses
ouvrages toutes ses qualités artistiques
de graphistes et des ouvrages très bien
construit qui font plaisir vraiment nous
en sommes voilà donc c'est beaucoup de
motifs qu'on trouve de l'arabesque
contre beaucoup dans les éditions des
grands classiques qu'est laquelle à la
designer pour king wind dont la coralie
bickford smith une artiste à suivre une
graphiste à suivre surtout voilà pour
les cadeaux de noël
est-ce que vous avez un agenda
particuliers ou des dédicaces
alors l'année 2019 ça va être une grosse
année pour le pavé du canal ce sera
notre honte
il va y avoir beaucoup d'événements
parlera plus tard des rencontres avec
des auteurs des éditeurs des
illustrateurs des événements culturels
au sein de la librairie avec des
choristes des danseurs voilà parfaite en
gros 500 votre site est appelé à
certifier sur les pages facebook
rapporte rabat sur facebook les gens
profitent également pour promouvoir
l'exposition de tous accueillons
l'exposition sur inuit du groenland
rouge en 2001 alors oui qui est à la
bibliothèque depuis à peu près le 10
décembre dans le hall de la bibliothèque
est ce qui permet également de donges
jusqu'alors qui s'étend jusqu'à la fin
de janvier par le voilà c'est une très
belle exposition qui a été réalisé par
le ses arcs par jean michel lux un
anthropologue et qui nous parle
aujourd'hui de cette communauté du
groenland par milliers merci beaucoup
armelle pour cet agenda
et puis je vous remercie beaucoup tous
le monde pour pouvoir assister vous deux
mesdames à cette dernière de l'année
j'étais envies de lecture et je remercie
aussi les téléspectateurs et je vous dis
à très bientôt sur tv 78 merci au revoir
[Musique]